I put food and Americans table all the
Truman's the segregation of the military
through an executive order showing
executive leadership and bringing
Americans together to activists like the
Lourdes water class reminding us
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my children meet me here in this country
told me and my daughter joined the
roster to stop taking away the footage I
choose to speak out
[Applause]
[Music]
you don't let you inside each a song so
much odorous
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
here brought my anniversary president
did not even acknowledge it and promote
it rally down to three
[Applause]
not all the English words but in actions
and policies
he has awoken a beast in our country
given a platform to unimaginable kinds
of hatred but he started his campaign in
the wrong City because we will not
tolerate it
to anyone who feels afraid to be their
authentic self because the client in the
Trump administration has perpetuated we
love you we stand with you and we will
not tolerate it in our home you have to
take action for those who cannot and it
starts with you and the youth plays such
a big factor in this
[Music]
if there was never a time paintball is
right now because even if these issues
don't directly affect you many
introduced into something much larger
affected us all and it has been a final
cloud hanging over our country for the
past three years and it is time to see
the Sun again
we cannot be tended in our actions we
must be bold and courageous it doesn't
matter how young you are do not ever let
someone tell you you are too young to
understand he has an odd kind of penny
for every time someone has tried to use
my age of insults I would have almost as
much money and Donald shut up from a
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
organizing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I was once someone who would only repost
me on social media until I realized that
was enough for you and I was fired by
the New Testament Douglas right here our
own sleep people my age turning their
pain into action marching for their
lives to make sure no more of my
classmates would get shot I want to let
everyone here know thank you
I started a bunch buzz watch their life
of the White House by passing out flyers
during lunch